Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to
Let's go to Casey from Oklahoma
City? Casey, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Anybody hear me OK? Yes, I can. What
Texas, R.P. Act, Oklahoma, Planned Parenthood,
I mean, they saw a jump, I think, in roughly like
2020 500 percent in patients. Hmm. But Governor
STAT, who's in the little brother of states and
governors like, you know, DeSantis and Abbott
just signed a law that would basically
upend it here in Oklahoma and ban it.
Yep. To include like $100000 in fines plus
a 10 year prison sentence. We did cover
Speaker 1: that story earlier this week. It's
crazy what Oklahoma is doing on abortion. Yeah.
Speaker 5: You know, but I find that we often
talk about, at least in the counter, we talk
about rape and incest, but one of the things
I never hear about is teen pregnancy. And if
we look at the top states on teen pregnancy is
greater than 30 per every thousand births. Guess
what? They're after all, Republic Republican
states, of course. South Carolina, Arizona,
Alabama, Tennessee. You know, I can go down the
list. What do you think that would help these
pro-life people to think twice when we reframe it
that the teen pregnancies who are their daughters?
Do you want them to keep their child? Or do they
say, well, morally, my daughters should keep it.
Speaker 1: So usually they will sidestep
this issue? You're absolutely right, which
is the places that have the highest rates of teen
pregnancy are mostly red states. That's absolutely
true. Republicans will sidestep this by saying If
we were correctly teaching abstinence only same
abstinence only sex education, they wouldn't
be getting pregnant in the first place. Now,
of course, they're wrong, but they want the
total package, which is ban abortion and teach
abstinence only, you know it doesn't work. I know
it doesn't work, but that's what they will say.
Speaker 5: I mean, I would think the coverage
of that is, isn't that what you already preach
in your states and obviously it's not working,
Speaker 1: it's not working now, but then they'll
they'll come in and they'll say no. But these
public schools with the critical race theory and
the gender stuff and the teaching kids how to have
sex and these that they'll just say it's not. It's
what we want, but it's not actually happening.
Teachers are injecting it into the classroom.
Speaker 5: Yeah, and it's a lot of Western snow
last night about a radio station here locally,
and if you go to like the FCC, they can't do
anything as far as freedom of speech, which
I'm all for freedom. Mm-Hmm. But the propaganda
from because they're playing like Infowars and
talking about demonic baby pedophile, all this
stuff is just infuriating. And I don't know
the solution to it because it's just making
people stronger in their beliefs that are
just untrue. It's lunacy. It's lunacy. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, Elizabeth is there in Oklahoma
because it's getting pretty
grim, I'm not going to lie.
Speaker 5: Yeah, it is.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right, Casey, thank
you for the call. Thank you. All right. There's
Casey from Oklahoma, the site of a horrifying,
horrifying, horrifying abortion bill. Let's go to
Tristan from Boston. Tristan, you're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Cool.
Speaker 5: It occurred to me recently.
Speaker 1: Have you considered
writing a book? Yes. In fact,
I'm working on a proposal right now. It's
a big project. That's a long process,
but I am working on that right now.
Speaker 5: Wow, that's actually pretty cool. Yeah.
If you don't mind me asking what is the subject?
Speaker 1: I don't want to say because we're still
workshopping it and then I might end up kind of
self cooking, you know, I don't want to do that.
Speaker 5: Does that include
elements of many subjects?
Speaker 1: It actually does, it actually does,
yeah. So it's a multidisciplinary proposal.
Speaker 5: I mean. That would feel
like the the main topics, the ideas
for the main topics would be pretty obvious.
Speaker 1: Well, we'll find out, won't we trust
Speaker 5: them, considering you're
considering your fields of expertize?
Speaker 1: Sure, sure. You know, when I have
more to say about it, I absolutely will,
but it's something I am working on.
Speaker 5:
That's actually great to hear. I would I would,
100 percent. I'm totally pumped to hear that.
Speaker 1: Well, good, it sounds like at least I'd
sell one copy. Can't wait to see it. All right,
Christine, thank you so much. All right,
there's Tristan from Boston asking about
a book project. Thanks to everybody who called
in. My apologies to everybody I couldn't get
to. We'll take calls again, and for now, we
will take a very quick break and be right back